Did they offer you drinks?
No - is this real?
Would you like a scotch, or there’s
apple juice if you’d rather?
I think Ardbeg would be
the right answer.
That’s my son!
Wolf - you’re home.
Finally.
Vesemir…
Yeah.
I had to make a few stops.
You made this really special for me,
because of the conversations that we
had about character,
and creating this
soulfulness and depth,
so you’ve made this a family for me,
where before I was just a lonely
witcher, all by my lonesome.
I was looking at you before
I met you in your earlier interviews
about how much you love
The Witcher world.
And you told me that you
wanted to travel inside your
emotional knowledge
that you have with Geralt.
And for me,
that’s everything, you know,
that’s my skills, I love that.
And you brought it, you brought it.
But that’s why it was easy
for me to tell about
what I thought were the elements
of the grounding in Vesemir.
I lived in the forest for twenty years-
Yes, yeah, you told me.
- and when I was done telling you
about my antics travelling,
and how it is to really be alone…
you said, “You are Vesemir.”
You were the last surviving witcher
after Kaer Morhen fell.
You and a batch of mutated orphans,
with nowhere else to go.
Were you ready?
No.
But you protected us anyway.
No. I taught you how
to fend for yourselves.
I trained everyday
in a new way of crying.
And that’s why I have to
travel inside my life
all the time because you don’t know
if there is more to cry about,
you know.
This is - I have this thing,
yes, absolutely.
I…once I’ve used something,
I’ve used it.
Yeah!
And then I’ve dealt with it.
I’ve emotionally processed it,
because I’ve been crying all day on set.
When I do this travelling all
the time it’s like my body
is getting more and more healthy.
Right.
So I’ve always thought…
that being an actor
is also healing myself,
it’s like to be a better person.
I think that’s the most
important thing for me
is to be a better person every day.
You did what you had to do.
You truly are Vesemir,
it’s the soul you bring
into the character,
that soulfulness which…
speaking specifically about the
relationship between Geralt and Vesemir,
they are incredibly emotional
with one another, and soulful,
but they’re so sad.
There’s such a deep sorrow in
Kaer Morhen because these are the last,
and each year less come back.
And these two incredibly
dangerous individuals
who are capable of
such extreme violence
and have survived extreme violence.
I know in some scenes
they didn’t make the cut,
but the softness we brought
and that connection,
just resting our heads
against each other’s heads,
and it just made so much sense,
because you can’t really fake that.
That’s why I love these moments
as an actor
where we can time travel
inside our minds.
Isn’t that beautiful?
It is beautiful.
And it’s so good to have someone
opposite you, who does it with you.
Yeah, yeah I know.
Like that moment in, um, the caves…
And it was very emotional.
It was.
It was beautiful, I don’t know
which version they chose, but…
I know, I know, and I also knew -
I mean I knew what they were
choosing but I…
you asked me to get emotional,
and you wanted Geralt
to be emotional this year,
and we talked a lot about how difficult
it is for us actors to put it in in serials
or in movies because you know,
we are not always allowed
to show so much emotion.
So the balance is
how much will be in the show,
and how much will not be in the show.
But for me, if you let yourself
do it on set,
the energy will be there,
and it will be inside you and inside me,
and that’s why I went the whole way!
Yes.
Also because I knew -
- we had to follow you in that scene.
So I knew that whatever I do in front
of the body of one of my sons,
that the camera would be on your face.
So if I was crying out - the whole day -
really deep inside crying out,
I knew I could put some
beautiful feelings inside you,
and the camera would see it,
because you couldn’t resist it
because it’s a sound.
It’s a primal reaction. Yeah.
Exactly! But that trust is the most
important thing we can have, you know.
I know you think I’m mad,
but I need to know what happened.
If it were your child, you’d be
going crazy to figure it out.
Thanks for watching,
thanks for watching our little chit chat.
This is basically an inside look into
what we did everyday on set,
and I hope you enjoy
watching The Witcher Season 2.